vous pensez que vous auriez pu vivre
heureux loin du pouvoir certainement
ouais alors Éveline Durieux vous êtes
peut-être celle autour de la table qui a
une vie pleine d'excès hein si je puis
dire puisque vous avez connu les fastes
le le luxe la démesure en épousant donc
le fils aîné de celui qui s'était
d'ailleurs autoproclamé empereur
l'empereur bookassa jusqu'à une vie
aujourd'hui plus modeste une vie normale
alors vous dites normale vous une vie
normale et vous dites enfin ou
malheureusement ah non non non enfin une
vie normale déjà avoir sa propre
identité parce que rentrer dans une
famille comme la famille de l'empereur
c'est rentrer dans un clan c'est c'est
quasiment oublier ses originesou oublier
sa famille pour adopter une politique et
pas une autre donc on est obligé de
rester très discret de pas sortir on
oublie ses amis on oublie sa propre
famille et on a très peu de liberté donc
ça je l'ai vécu pendant plusieurs années
ce qui fait que pendant longtemps j'ai
oublié moi-même qui j'étais réellement
si ce n'est que pour rentrer dans la
peau de de quelqu'un qui devait jouer un
rôle représentatif et aujourd'hui vous
êtes enfin vous-même c'est ça que vous
voulez nous dire aujourd'hui j'ai assumé
ma chute indirectement je dirais mais ça
chute mais au départ ce qui est amusant
quand vous dites ça non j'ai chuté c'est
pas de ma faute oui mais parce que vous
étiez donc on disait donc fille
d'entrepreneur oui pas appelé à priori à
une à des sains pareil Jéromine j'aurais
pu épouser un avocat ou un médecin ou un
notaire mais oui alors dans le fond
c'est une chute par accident c'est ce
que je voulais dire oui c'est une chute
par
accident c'est l'issu d'une rencontre
voilà tout à fait inopportune donc une
rencontre d'amour oui avec votre ancien
mari normal à 16 ans enfin c'est normal
de tomber amoureuse donc en plus il y
avait tout le contexte qui se prêtait
pour que les choses se passent bien et
facilement et cetera quand vous dites
tout y était est-ce que ce qu'il reprend
présenté vous a attiré on sait bien que
souvent le pouvoir attire aussi il y
avait la personnalité parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui était très fort qui était
convaincant qui avait des moyens en plus
pour convaincre et on avait qu'une seule
envie c'est de se laisser porter dans
cette situation il y avait pas lieu de
de se soucier de l'avenir ou quoi que ce
soit alors comment passe-t-on du statut
de princesse et future impératrice futur
reine à celui de simple vendeuse je
dirais que le parcours n'est pas facile
du tout parce que justement il y a une
dégringolade du jour au lendemain à
savoir qu'on se retrouve en exil ou sans
papier ou sans domicile et qu'il faut
tout repositionner dans sa vie tous les
jours voilà alors en épousant George
bocassa vous êtes entré vous de plein
pied dans l'histoire une histoire qui a
vite dégénéré vous êtes passé du rêve de
l'illusion à la dure réalité c'est vrai
que vous semblez très sereine avec votre
époux actuel oui c'est un fils de paysan
ses parents sont agriculteurs
et donc le parcours s'est refait
complètement à l'envers en commençant
par travailler à refaire une maison
qu'on a fait
nous-même il reconstruit avec vous il
est dans le présent ili c'est un qui se
lève tous les matins et qui va au
travail bon pour nourrir sa famille donc
il a raison d'être comme il est
c'est-à-dire avec beaucoup de recul
beaucoup de pondération et s com il
regarde robe de Princess il regarde
pas alors que vous quand vous les
montrer hein quand vous les regardez il
y a une certaine si je puis dire
nostalgie je suis contente d'avoir eu
des belles choses à porter voilà quoi
c'est tout si aujourd'hui on m'offre une
jolie robe je serais contente c'est
toujours le R de la petite fille vous
vous êtesêtes Plô làdedans c'est ma
nature qui est comme ça mais je veux
dire j'ai aussi prouvé que je je prenais
le chemin de de du enfin du travail et
puis sans passe droit donc je me suis
pas présentée en disant voilà vous savez
j'étais ceci ou cela pas du tout au
moment de la séparation avec George
bocassa vous êtes retrouvé du jour au
lendemain sans rien ah moi je suis
partie sans rien j'ai quitté un château
en emmenant rien du tout parce que vous
ne vous entendiez plus donc on va dire
un séparation de couple I et les mains
dans les poches ah oui sans rien sans
rien sans rien mais bon le plus tragique
dans l'histoire c'est que j'ai fini par
aussi laisser mes enfants parce que je
n'étais pas dans une situation où je
pouvais les emmener dans dans une autre
galère c'est c'était pas raisonnable non
plus Jéromine Pasteur comment vous
ragissezv à l'histoire d'Eveline vous
qui vivez plutôt dépouillé de tout ben
j'ai vu tout à l'heure que Eveline avait
une petite larme et je la comprends et
j'en ai eu une avec elle quelle petite
larme ah ben c'est fou ce qu'elle a vécu
c'est fou quoi quand on est petite fille
moi je crois j'ai vu Blanche-Neige j'ai
vu j'ai vu toutes ces Walt Disney ou
qu'est-ce qui est bien c'est d'être
Cendrillon et de venir la la jolie
petite princesse on nous a éduqué avec
ça donc je comprends que Eveline est
plus tomberé amoureuse d'un prince
prince moi je donc plutôt que d'épouser
un notaire vous pensiez épouser un
prince te dire voilà tout simplement
est-ce que vous porter quand même parce
que tout le monde se pose la question
autour du du coup qui brille ce sont des
ce sont des faux oui mais ça c'est pour
me faire plaisir c'est ça n'a rien à
vooir non non sont des diamants ou pas
c'est dé faux son des faux ah bah
voilà alors Eveline comment comment on
vit C ces fastes là quand on est quand
on est jeune parce qu'on vous a vu là
c'est vous qui assistiez donc au sacre
de bokasa comment vous avez vu vécu tout
ça un peu dans une sorte d'irréalité
j'imagine quand on est dedans on a du
mal à voir vraiment le ressenti par
rapport à l'extérieur mais par rapport
au couronnement je dirais que c'était un
événement bon il a été ce qu'il a été
évidemment on aurait très largement pu
s'en passer mais pour avoir été au cœur
de l'action euh c'est quelque chose que
je n'oublierai jamais je n'oublierai
jamais ces instants où il met la
couronne et on entend que des
crépitements la salle est muette on
entend que les crépitements des flash et
ça ça me ça me reste quoi cela dit à
l'époque il y avait beaucoup de
représentants du monde entier qui
s'était qui s'était déplacé n'est-ce pas
Michel de grresse oui peu de royauté
mais enfin beaucoup de représentants de
Diplomat alors on voit une différence
d'ailleurs entre vos enfants ceux que
vous avez eu avec donc Joël votre mari
on sent que ça les fait pas du tout
rêver hein métier princesse elles disent
alors ça c'est de la souffrance et je
voyais mich dire ah ils ont bien
raison loin de là parce que ils ont un
exemple sous leurs yeux avec les
grands-parents donc les parents de mon
mari qui sont agriculteurs et qui
travaillent toute la journée dans les
champs donc pour eux les paillettes
c'est c'est pas dans leur environnement
quotidien alors Geoffre vous qui portez
vous le nom de bokasa le nom de votre
père c'est plus difficile par rapport
aux autres enfants de de votre mère
comment réagissent les gens à ce nom
il réagissent surtout premièrement par
toutes les petites histoires qu'ils ont
entendu t les on dit et racontard et moi
maintenant qui suis âgé de de 23 ans
très âgé non c'est pas ça mais c'est que
maintenant je peux répondre à quelqu'un
tandis que quand on est arrivé en savoir
ou quoi que ce soit pendant 10 ans
j'étais incapable de pouvoir exprimer
vraiment ce que je pensais puisque
quelqu'un un adulte arrive vers vous tu
t'appelles Bokassa g agressif ou
intéressé pas intéressé de toute façon
quand on vient vous parler de de crime
ou de meurtre ou de choses dans genre on
vient pas vous en parler avec le sourire
donc donc c'était plutôt lourd à porter
ce qui est lourd maintenant en fait je
dirais plus c'est que c'est maintenant
que je suis en âge de bien comprendre
tout ça que j'ai vraiment le plus envie
de de pouvoir tout comprendre d'avoir de
vraies sources d'information Eveline
vous vous n'êtes plus embêté par ce
passé puisque vous avez récupéré votre
nom c'est pas être embêté mais si vous
voulez c'est accepter certaines erreurs
et le poids des situations il faut les
vivre accepter ses souffrances accepter
qu'on ait un regard un petit peu
interrogateur quelquefois et les gens se
disent tiens bookassa mais c'est lui qui
mangeait des gens c'est lui qui donnait
des diamants à tour de bras oui ok ça
c'est une partie de l'histoire
maintenant on vit avec mais nous on est
autrement c'est surtout la répression
meurtrière he qu'il y a eu lors des
meutes et des opposants au régime à
l'époque bien sûr je vais vous dire
honnêtement la chose que je regrette
c'est de pas pouvoir discuter avec mon
grand-père maintenant sur toute cette
période là l'ex empereur Bassa tout à
fait cela dit vous pouvez le faire avec
votre père là c'est quelque chose qui
prendra très
longtempsin lui en plus c'est quelqu'un
qui vit relativement dans dans son passé
encore maintenant même il est retourné
en Centrafrique c'est il y retourne lui
il y est il y est il y est ouais ouais
il y est et apparemment on recommence
là-bas un peu à construire quelque chose
donc j'ai hâte de savoir et d'y aller
parce que maintenant je suis assez fort
pour pouvoir le faire moi mon ex-mi a
été un poste important en tant que
ministre de la Défense donc très vite on
s'est aperçu qu'il y avait des liens de
de de concurrence il y avait de des
jalousies il y avait des dénonciations
il y avait de la délation il y avait une
milice personnelle qui trahissait donc
tout ça tout cela confondu on s'est
retrouvé un jour en état d'arrestation
et on est obligé de quitter le
territoire moi je je me suis évadé trois
fois quand même du pays où je suis né où
mon père a créé son entreprise
donc vos parents qu'ils ont pensé de ce
mariage bah fatalement j'ai eu droit à
la remarque tu vois je te l'avais dit ça
finalement c'est sûr mes parents me
l'ont me l'ont fait remarquer mais moi
je pourquoi je n'aurais pas cru à cette
histoire si si georgeavais suivi son
parcours en tant que fils aîné bon chef
de tribu ou quoi que ce soit mais avec
une fonction indépendante de celle de
son père on aurait très bien pu vivre
heureux à l'écart de tout ça vous pensez
que vous auriez pu pu vivre heureux loin
du pouvoir certainement ouais loin du
pouvoir hein loin du pouvoir oui
autrement dit exiler à vie quoi vous en
avez souffert vous à un moment donné
vous j'ai souffert pour mes enfants
parce que eux ne sont pas responsables
de ça et finalement je crois que là où
je suis très contente aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir de leur avoir montré que il faut
accepter cette situation les faits sont
les fait il y a des gens qui ont
souffert il y a des gens qui sont morts
Geoffrey n'aura pas toutes les rép aux
questions qu'il se pose c'est important
pour lui il nous dit aujourd'hui qu'il
aille en centra-frique pour voir le
chemin et poser un nom sur des éléments
sur sur des monuments sur des rues et
cetera ça c'est normal mais ils n'ont
pas à se justifier parce que ils ont
leur chemin à faire du moment qu'ils se
tiennent droit qu'ils ont une vie
honnête ils n'ont pas justifié de choses
qu'ils n'ont pas faites on n pas rougir
mon fils est là il travaille il faudra
peut-être une ou deux générations pour
que les choses vraiment saténue mais
l'histoire elle s'est écrite comme ça
peut-être dans le sang mais c'est comme
ça et aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous
faites vous ben moi aujourd'hui j'ai une
vie de saisonnière en fait en Savoie
donc j'ai fait mes études dans le
bâtiment où je suis maçon coffreur voilà
et l'hiver je travaille en station je
trouve à prendre tout mon plaisir dans
le cadre de vie que ma mère s'est vertué
nous installé en Savoie quoi j'admire
beaucoup ce jeune homme parce qu'il ne
renit pas son passé oui c'est ça qui for
il a un passé très difficile un nom très
difficile au lieu de jeter en l'air et
de dire moi ça ne m'intéresse plus il ne
le renit pas
et j'admire beaucoup ça je dois dire
parce que ce n'est pas courant c'est
vrai voil en moi c'est ça qui me plaît
beaucoup c'est de faire le trajet en
plus a c'est presque symbolique enfin il
y a le trajet on le voit en face et et
on se trouve et on prend sa décision
c'est très bien ça c'est c'est vraiment
ce qu'il faut faire pas
hiter vous êtes jamais vraiment
intéressé au grand ce monde les rois les
princes les ereurs je suis désolé mais
ça me fait hurler de rire je suis désolé
vraiment mais parce que non c'est pas
c'est pas gentil de dire ça mais c'est
vrai que quand quand je voyais le
couronnement c'était c'était c'était
vraiment formidable on avait
l'impression de quand j'étais gosse on
jouit à ce couronné aussi comme ça des
enfants sont se coutit des trucs sur la
tête on faisait des défilés ça me fait
un peu penser à la même chose alors
jamais vous êtes toujours plutôt dans un
milieu vous euh bourgeois petit
bourgeois que vous avezvous connu dans
votre enfance oui c'est ça petit
bourgeois n'exagérez pas moyenne
bourgeoisie moyenne bourgeoisie moyen
bourisie pardon pardon du peu CLA CHR et
et B oui c'était c'est pour moi c'était
c'est c'est ces gensl que je connais le
mieux donc le je les connais même en
profondeur et puis il m'amuse et vous
êtes sans
pitié pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne
in mire dum abonnez-vous et AC la
[Musique]
cloche